hey youtubers it's Charlie and the
Oscars are here I'll be doing a proper
Oscars winners video tonight but I
wanted to do a video honoring all of our
favorite fandoms and fandom actors that
we think should win an Oscar because the
Oscars are one of the most
professionally recognized and respected
award shows I'm gonna be bending the
rules so I can include things like
Doctor Who and other television shows
Oscar's are normally just for movies for
motion pictures and you could argue that
the People's Choice Awards is kind of
like the fandom Oscars but because the
Oscars is mostly voted on by a group of
old men I thought it'd just be fun to do
our own Awards so let's have some fun
with this and just do Best Picture Best
Actor Best Actress and Best Supporting
Actor actress the really funny thing
about all this is that sometimes actors
that when real-life Oscars actually have
starred in some of your favorite fandoms
in the past it's just that some people
are directors or writers get their start
on the science fiction genre show and
then later in life go on to become
hugely successful part of the reason I
wanted to do this is that most of the
time that people that vote on the
real-life Oscars really hate science
fiction in genre for instance
Christopher Nolan has only ever been
nominated for an Oscar for his memento
Screenplay and for inception he didn't
win either of them Inception lost to
King's Speech which is exactly the kind
of movie you would call Oscar bait so
let's talk about our favorite stuff in
people we feel deserve Oscars feel free
to add stuff in the comments if I don't
mention it in the video let's start with
Best Supporting Actress we have to start
with Michelle Fairley for the red
wedding
she's amazing these Catelyn Stark in
general and since the show is so
serialized all include her even though
technically it's part of the Emmys then
there's Amanda Abbington in his last vow
as Mary Morstan now Mary Morstan Watson
they have to compete with Evangeline
Lilly one of the few females in
desolation of smaug this year but an
amazing performance nonetheless feel
free to make any more suggestions for
best supporting actress in the comments
but next is Best Supporting Actor we
have to include Lars Mikkelsen
as Charles Augustus Magnussen such a
great villain and every bit as scary as
his brother Mads Mikkelsen in Hannibal
then there's both David Tennant and John
Hurt in the Doctor Who 50th anniversary
episode we have to include Philip
Seymour Hoffman from Catching Fire
Idris Elba and Pacific Rim and I would
like to nominate all of the
orbs from desolation of smaug as one
collective group they could just share
an Oscar statue if they won technically
we also have to include Benedict
Cumberbatch as Smaug the dragon in this
category because even though Smaug is
very big I consider him a supporting
character in the story on to Best
Actress though these are the leads from
each movie or fandom starting with the
easy one Jennifer Lawrence and Catching
Fire she'll get attention at the actual
Oscars for American hustle but it's
probably her Hunger Games stuff that
most of us know her from the other easy
ones being Sandra Bullock and gravity
and Scarlett Johansson in her great
science fiction if you have not seen
them yet some of the few science fiction
movies that are actually getting legit
recognition this awards season there's
actually a lot of lead actresses on my
genre awards list so I'll try to keep it
down there's Jessica Chastain and
Guillermo del Toro's horror movie mama
Rinko Kikuchi in Pacific Rim one of the
most badass female characters all year
both Kristen Bell and idina menzel and
frozen they should also win for let it
snow the song too and I can't leave off
Amy Acker and Joss Whedon's much ado
about nothing
leading for shout out on to Best Actor
starting off with Benedict Cumberbatch
and Martin Freeman for the entirety of
Sherlock series 3 Matt Smith in the 50th
anniversary special tony leung in one
car wise grandmaster as if man so
awesome Aleksey Denisof also in much ado
about nothing and i kind of want to
include Tom Hiddleston for only lovers
left alive but they moved the release
dates so technically it's a 2014 movie
and lastly we have to include Peter
Dinklage for everything but mostly for
Game of Thrones on to Best Picture so I
tried to narrow it down to the best of
the best there were a lot of awesome
things and some of them are actually
getting recognized at the real-life
Fosters so it's really cool first
they're spike Jones's her it was
actually my favorite theatrical film
this year next to Miyazaki's the wind
rises two movies that you absolutely
have to see wind rises is actually
nominated for Best Foreign Language Film
which I totally hope it wins but I think
it should also be included for Best
Picture overall then there's desolation
of smaug it was one of the only movies
in addition to the wind rises that I
picked to see more than once in a movie
theater then there's gravity from
Alfonso Cuaron I love all of his movies
but gravity
amazing and that's my winners wishlist
so let me know what is your favorite
sci-fi or genre movie this year and let
me know why you think it deserves an
Oscar like I said I'll be doing an
actual Oscar video tonight after the
winners are announced be sure to
subscribe to get that I'll also be
posting a new Walking Dead episode right
now click here for that Oscar video I'll
add the annotation as soon as I post the
video tonight and click here to catch up
on Walking Dead before tonight's episode
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives